[Music]
we threw bread every year like this is
our independent days
[Music]
Natha means that they aviators the
independence from Russia and China
[Music]
[Applause]
and after each war we won't be used to
celebrate like this festival
the artery are thriving and wrestling my
favorite is of course the wrestling it
doesn't matter you are small or big you
compete and only one champion wrestling
is my favorite there's a lot of hot guys
there horse because I love ours in the
culture self every Mongolian people can
ride a horse
we love the ho shoo
the best food in Festival and is so
delicious actually
but you have to find out that which one
is the best because here is so many kind
of there for sure
this is be hiring container then we fire
up the stones and we take out the stones
and we pop it through our ends with ease
for our toe and the meat is really tasty
[Music]
name of the spell by national customs a
long time ago we have to every day used
using these costumes this is not a
traditional is like more fashionable
prick the tradition and more like
decoration and stuff we can stylish
specified
[Music]